.
In this presentation I want to solve a bunch of examples of analysis
Multilevel class II, which is what
Also called quadratic equation
At some times you write a quadratic quadratic equation, or
A quadratic equation only, or quadratic, but all mean
Multilevel Class II
Anything that contains a raised variable
Of the second force
In this case, in all the examples that we will solve, x will be
So let's assume that I have the square statement x ^ 2
+ 10x + 9
I want to analyze it to the sum of two double-edged phrases
how to do that?
Well, let's think about what will happen if we want to
Take x + a, and hit it with x + b
If we want to hit these two things, what happens?
Well, we have some experience to do this
This will be x x x, equal to x ^ 2, + x x b
Ie bx, + (a × x) + (a × b) -i + ab
Or if we want to combine the two phrases in the middle
Because both are operators for x
We can write this as x ^ 2 + - I can type it
b + a or a + b - x + ab
If in general, if we assume that this is the product of multiplication
With these two bounds, we see that the lab is middle
For the x, or you can say the formula coefficient of the class
This will be the sum of a and b
And then the constant will be a beat
a and b
Note that this relates to this, and this
Related to this
Of course, this is equivalent to this
Can we analogize this and that?
Is there a and b so that a + b = 10?
And a × b = 9?
Well, let's think about this a bit
What are the 9 factors?
What can be the value of a and b?
We assume that the whole numbers are correct
And naturally when we analyze the factors, especially when
We start analysis, we deal
With correct numbers
What are the 9 factors?
It's 1, 3 and 9
If it can be 3 and 3, it can be 1 and 9
Now, if 3 and 3, therefore you have 3 + 3 - this
Not equal to 10
But if 1 and 9, the 1 × 9 = 9
And 1 + 9 = 10
This has worked
If a = 1, and b = 9
We can analyze it to be (x + 1)
× (x + 9)
If you hit them, use that skill
We have developed it in recent presentations, you will see this
Really equals x ^ 2 + 10x + 9
When you see something like that, when it is a coefficient
The expression x ^ 2, or the subsequent parameter
The quadratic formula is 1, you can say, well, what the two are
Are the two numbers equal to this coefficient?
What are the two numbers
They are the same numbers, when you take the sum of their beat
It should equal 9
Of course, it should be typical
Or if it is not in the typical form, you should place it
So shape, so you can always say, OK, whatever
The coefficient of the first-order phrase, a and b
Their sum must be this
No matter how hard I am, the sum of a × b must be
Be that
Let's solve more examples
I think the more we solve the more examples, the more
We got the idea better
Let's assume that we have x ^ 2 + 10x + - ok
I've used 10x already, so let's use a different number - x ^ 2
+ 15x + 50
And we want to analyze it
Well, we'll use the same idea
We have x ^ 2
We have a first class statement
This should be a total of two numbers
Then this phrase, no hard
It should be a sum of two numbers
So we need to think twice when we hit them
We get 50, and when we collect them, we get 15
This will be the kind of art that you are doing
Develop it, but the more you practice, you'll see
You will be able to get it automatically
So what can be the values ​​of a and b?
Let's think about the 50 factors
Can be 1 x 50
2 x 25
Let's see, 50 can not be divided by 4
It can be 5 x 10
I think these are all
Let 's try these numbers, and see any
Of which a total of 15
If 1 + 50 is not equal to 15
2 + 25 Their sum is not equal to 15
But 5 + 10 the total of 15
So the two numbers are 5 + 10, and can be 5 x 10
If we want to analyze it, it becomes x +
5) (x + 10)
We beat them
I encourage you to hit them, and you see that
Really equals x ^ 2 + 15x + 10
In fact, let's do this, x x x = x ^ 2, and x
× 10 = 10x
5 x x = 5x
5 x 10 = 50
Note, that 5 × 10 = 50
5x + 10x has given us 15x in the middle
If we get x ^ 2 + 15x + 50
Let's move forward, so we'll get some
Negative signals are here
Suppose we have x ^ 2 - 11x + 24
Now, this follows the same rule
I need to think about two numbers, when I have them together
The result is -11
That is, a + b must equal -11
And a × b must be equal to 24
Now, there is something here to think about
When I hit both of these numbers, I'll get the
Positive number
Which is 24
This means that both of them must be positive, or both
They must be negative
That's the only way I'll get a positive number here
Now, when I have them together, I will get a negative number, if they are
There is no way that I can collect two positive numbers
And get a negative number, since their sum is
The number is negative, since the result of their positive multiplication
This tells me that both a and b are negative
a and b must be negative
Remember, neither can be negative or the other
Positive, because the outcome of their beating will be negative
Neither can be positive, because when we bring them together
The result will be a positive number
So let's think about what can be the value of a and b
If there are two
Let's think about the 24 factors
We have to think about negative factors
But let me see, it can be 1 x 24, 2 x 11, 3 x
8, or 4 × 6
Now, any of these numbers when I hit them - well
Clearly when I hit 1 x 24, I'll get 24
When I take 2 x 11 - sorry, this is 2 × 12--
I'll get 24
We know that all this will be 24
But any two of them, ie, two factors, when combined
Will I get 11?
Then we can say, let's take
Both are negative
If we look at these, we will see 3 and 8
3 × 8 = 24
3 + 8 = 11
But that did not work, did it?
Because we have -11 here
But what if they are 3 and 8?
-3 × -8 = positive 24
-3 + -8 = positive 11
He succeeded 3 and 8
If we analyze this, x ^ 2 - 11x + 24
It is equal to (x - 3) (x - 8)
Let's solve one another like this
In fact, let me put it a little
Let's assume that I have x ^ 2 + 5x-14
If we have a different case here
The number of multiples is negative, is not it? a × b
= -14
The product is negative
This tells us that one of them is positive, and one
negative
When combined, a + b = 5
So let's think about 14 factors
And what are their components, which when I gather them, if one
Positive and one negative, or in fact I will
The difference between them, will I get 5?
If I take 1 and 14 - I'll try the numbers--
1 and 14, -1 + 14 = -13
-1 + 14 = 13
Let me write down all the ingredients that can be taken
Your brain will divide it
If we get -1 + 14 = 13
And 1 + -14 = -13
If these two numbers do not work
This is not equal to 5
Now what about for 2 and 7?
If you take 2 - let me write it in a different color - if
I took 2 + 7, this is equal to 5
We are done!
This has worked
I mean, we can try 2 + 7, but that
Equals -5, if this does not work
But succeeded 2 and 7
And 2 × 7 = -14
We got it
We know that (x - 2) (x + 7)
This is nicely done
-2 × 7 = -14
-2 + 7 = positive 5
Let's solve more of them, so we gain
This skill
Let's assume that we have x ^ 2 - x - 56
If the multiplication of these two numbers should be 56
It should be -56
The difference between them, because one will be positive
The other is negative, right?
The difference between them should be -1
And the numbers that will directly inform me
- I do not know if it has occurred to you
We have learned that this is in multiplication tables
- 56 = 8 × 7
I mean there are other numbers
It's also 28 x 2
There are many numbers
But 8 × 7 has really scared me, because they are
Very close together
We need numbers to be close together
One must be positive, and the other must
To be negative
Now, when their sum is negative, this tells me that
The greater number of these two should be negative
If we take 8 × 7, this is
Equals -56
Hence if we take 8 + 7, this is equal
-1, which is the parameter found here
When I analyze them, x (8)
× (x + 7)
This is often the most difficult concept that people learn
In algebra, because it is a kind of art
You have to look at all the factors here, manipulating
Negative and positive signals, and see which of these factors
Shall be positive, and any of them shall be negative, and their sum shall be equal
For the x statement parameter
But whenever you solve more questions, you'll see that
It becomes obvious
Now let's intensify the exercises more
Let's say we have -x ^ 2 - everything we've done
Recently, his treatment was positive
The coefficient of the expression x ^ 2 is positive 1
But let's assume that we have -x ^ 2
- 5x + 24
How do we solve it?
Well, the simplest way I can think of is to extract the common factor
-1, and then become similar to the issues
Which we have dealt with previously
If this is equivalent to -1 × (x ^ 2
+ 5x - 24)
is not it?
I extracted the 1
You can hit -1 with all this, and will
You see it will become as it was
Or you can extract the -1 and divide all
This is on -1
And you'll get this
Now, as we did before
We will need two numbers, when we hit them we get
If one of them is positive, the other negative
And when I take their sum
When I take their total, it will be 5
So let's think about 24, which is 1 and 24
Let's see, if this is -1 and 24, then their sum will be positive 23
If it is the opposite, it will be -23
Did not succeed
What about for 2 and 12?
Well, if this - - Remember, one of these two numbers should
Be negative
If 2 is the negative number, the sum will be 10
If the 12 is negative, their total will be -10
It did not work either
3 and 8
If the 3 are negative, the sum is 5
If it has succeeded
If we choose 3 and 8, 3 and 8 will meet our demand
Because -3 + 8 = 5
-3 × 8 = -24
If this equals - I can not forget it
There are -1 abroad, then we analyze the inside
-1 × (x - 3) (x + 8)
If you really want to, you can hit
1. With this, you will get 3
- x
Or you are not forced to do so
Let's solve one another
Let us solve another issue on this
That's enough practice for you, I think
That's good, suppose we have -x ^ 2
+ 18x - 72
Again, I prefer to extract -1
If this equals -1 × (x ^ 2
- 18x + 72
Now we have to think about two dimensions, when
Make a positive
If their signals are similar
This makes it simple, at least until I do it mentally
When you hit them, get 72
When I get them together, I get -18
If they have the same signal, their total will be
A negative number, if both must be negative
Both are negative
We can address all 72 factors
But whatever you think, maybe 8 × 9
But 8 × 9, or -8-9, or -8 +
-9, do not succeed
Because their sum is 17
It was soon
Let me make it clear to you
-9 + -8 = -17
Very close, but not what is required
What are the other factors?
We have 6 and 12
That sounds good
If we have -6 + -12, this is equal
Note, it's an art
You have to try different factors here
If it becomes -1 - do not forget
That is - × (x - 6) (x - 12)
.